hello and welcome everyone to today's
brilliant minds bold questions virtual
talk
our series spotlights high impact
research from across the academy from
computer science population and public
health to economics and today molecular
microbiology if you are not familiar
with us cfar is a global research
organization that convenes extraordinary
minds to address the most important
questions facing science and humanity
my name is kay getty i am senior
director of research at seafarer and it
is my distinct pleasure to introduce you
to our two speakers for today's talk on
what actually killed the dinosaurs
first we have arturo casa de vol who is
a bloomberg distinguished professor of
molecular microbiology and immunology
and infectious diseases at the johns
hopkins bloomberg school of public
health and john hopkins school of
medicine
his research focuses on host defense
mechanisms how fungi cause disease and
in the development of antibody-based
therapies for infectious diseases
he is also the advisory committee chair
of seafarers program on the fungal
kingdom threats and opportunities
second we have rebecca shapiro a cfar
azraeli global scholar in the same
fungal kingdom threats and opportunities
program
rebecca is assistant professor in the
department of molecular and cellular
biology at the university of guelph
where she examines the biology and
pathogenesis of certain fungal species
today's session will last approximately
30 minutes
i will start with a question before
inviting our speakers to ask one another
questions for about 20 to 25 minutes
after this i will open it up to
questions from participants online so if
you're an online audience member and
have a question you can use the q a
function to submit it
we do ask that you not use the chat
function to submit questions
lastly
this session is being recorded and will
be available on the cfr website next
week
so to get us started
most of us are brought up to believe
that a meteor hit the earth leading to
the extinction of the dinosaurs but as
this talk title suggests it seems that
it might not be quite so simple
what is missing from this widely held
idea and how do fungi get it
so uh kate thank you for your question
and thank you for inviting me i think
the
the general explanation that amir that a
meteor did it is the right explanation i
mean but there are nuances to this
um
the the event is thought to have been a
collision from something about
17 miles in length that hit the yucatan
65 million years ago
and it would have caused a tremendous
calamity
in the earth
massive
tsunamis
going through north america rapid
warming of the atmosphere massive amount
of dust
and then fires on the earth so anything
at the top of the food chain would have
been in trouble dinosaurs were at the
top of the food chain
but
the and probably
perhaps some survive but the question is
what happened
in the aftermath of the calamity what
happened in the month and the years
after that
and
what hopefully we'll talk about is is a
world dominated by the fungi
and anything that survives anything that
made it then would have had to deal with
a massive fungal bloom as the planet
became a global compost
so i i think maybe jumping in on that
you know what then precisely uh were
the sort of conditions of the this
post-meteor world and how did they
specifically um
kind of favor fungal growth
so uh there has been a lot of work
reconstructing the calamity um the um
you can imagine that the the immediate
blast uh
would have led to uh rapid heating of
the atmosphere
uh and then these shock waves would have
basically
a win around the world uh and and two
two things will happen then the the
tsunamis the shockwaves will have
knocked down the trees but the what
really hurts the plant life is
large numbers
large
millions of tons of earth are basically
kicked into low orbit
and these now will obscure the sun
shutting down photosynthesis
now many of those rocks are in unstable
orbits and will
begin to come down and they come down as
flaming meteorites
so you have fires you have the depth of
vegetation
and you have rapid cooling
the earth cools very rapidly after that
so you have dark
uh dead vegetation and cool and those
are the ideal
uh
conditions for a fungal bloom
so where does then the link
with dinosaur extinctions come in so
given the sort of conditions that are
favored now in this really terrible
sounding you know apocalyptic world you
know how how why are fungi then favoring
um
uh
infection in in dinosaurs at this stage
then so uh what the the way i look at it
is that clearly things survive we're
here
so
clearly our mammalian ancestors made it
uh clearly or reptilians made it we have
reptiles today we got iguanas insects
mated
um
um dinosaurs didn't make it but you know
dinosaurs were in all kinds of shape uh
from enormous to to smaller ones
and um
one
one
a potential explanation for this is that
uh certainly
mammals with their internal combustion
engines
uh they remain warm
the others
certainly the reptiles didn't what
happens when reptiles are cold they
can't move they can't digest food
so
these conditions would have given a huge
advantage already to anything that was
warm and now
you could add the fungal spores
so
in this cataclysmic
post apocalyptic war you would have had
massive amounts of fungal spores
and it you can always
overcome an immune system with a
sufficient inoculum
so for the cold-blooded animals
they would have been at a great
disadvantage not only nutritionally not
only moving around but now having to
deal with massive numbers of hunger
sports in the meantime
our small ancestors would have done well
they could move they could eat mushrooms
they could eat all kinds of things and
they would establish much larger
populations
so when the sky is cleared
and the earth begins to recover now you
have a lot more mammals then you have
reptiles
large
founder populations and then you have
the age of mammals
and
what
do do we have any real do we have like
concrete evidence from the fossil record
for this how do we you talked about you
know huge blooms of spores in this time
do we do we know that that happened yes
there is fungal there is in the fossil
record uh
uh what is known the kt boundary that is
the cretaceous tertiary boundary there
is evidence for massive fungal
proliferation not only there but if you
go back in time this happened 65 million
years ago if you go back to the
to the permian extinction
uh there the the fungal layer in some
parts of south africa is as much as one
meter
think about that one meter of fungal
sports
so anything that survives
the fungi will always do well when
things go bad for other organisms okay
they
and they do very well because they tend
to degrade matter
uh
and and they will survive in these
environments and they when they survive
they produce larger spores and large
amounts of spores means that you have to
make it through this fungal bloom
so yes there is there is fossil evidence
for
massive fungal proliferation the in
those two great calamities the permian
and the the kt boundary
and so so so it seems like you know
temperature really then is the big
player here that
um you know warm blooded mammals sort of
had the advantage here to protect
themselves um you know against fungal
infection so
how does that how does that sort of play
out you know in the world today
um and if we're thinking about
i don't know a chain a world of changing
climate and temperature you know if
how will this potentially impact what we
see
with fungi today and susceptibility of
different kinds of animals
that's a great question rebecca uh the
i mean the the way i i came into this
was because it always bothered me the
question why mammals
i already had three meals today
you know if i was reptilian i can
probably do with one meal a week
i mean how do we end up having
selecting large animals that have to eat
all the time uh that doesn't make any
sense to me unless there was a selection
mechanism
something had to favor being hot
uh and and the and then so this so what
i the way i think about it is that this
temperature
creates a thermal gradient between us
and the outside now it turns out
that we looked at a susceptibility of
fungi to temperature
about 10 years ago and most fungal
species cannot tolerate 37 degrees they
simply stop growing so just being 37
degrees is giving you a tremendous
protection
against the fungal kingdom which is by
the way the major passages of plants
a cold-blooded animal insects and many
others
uh so guess what's happening in the
world today the world is getting warmer
so it what is this going to do
well
one you have a lot of organisms out
there that maybe the the temperature max
is 34 35 36 degrees but they are loaded
with the capacity to cause disease in
other organisms but they can break
through your temperature barrier but
what would happen if they adapted
then uh as a result of a warmer climate
then we can be posed we can be facing
new threats
from the we we don't even know yet
because they haven't been a problem up
to now
and so and i guess you know adding on to
the the kind of temperature question
here then where do where do other
animals fit in i think if my
basic biology is correct i think birds
are even you know warmer than
um us humans so are they are birds gonna
take over the world next is that gonna
be kind of our our trajectory from here
well
it's interesting you i'm glad you bring
in the birds so the birds and the
mammals are the two and by the way the
crocodiles i don't know what's going on
with the crocodiles but the birds and
mammals and the crocodiles are the major
groups that make it
through the do well after the kd
calamity the birds are already pretty
hot the birds are
quite resistant to fungal diseases
except for one kind of fungus type which
are already thermally adapted and that's
the aspergillus the aspergillus family
is often what you find in a compost you
know you drive by you see a compost you
see smoke coming out those are uh fungi
they're carrying on metabolism these are
fungus those fungi are already quite
adapted and for whatever reason
uh the birds are susceptible to to
aspirations but they are pretty
resistant to everything else you can't
for example you pigeons are associated
with cryptocuses but you can't give a
pigeon a cryptococcal infection because
their temperature is 42 so they are able
to do so so uh the birds why are the
birds hot probably because flight
requires a tremendous
investment in energy and the harder the
energy the more efficient it is
so it turns out that indica in the case
of birds in the case of the primitive
mammals that were around they were
pre-adapted perhaps for different
conditions
very interesting
and so maybe to kind of circle back to
kate's original question then you know
how did this whole idea emerge how did
you put you know how did this theory
sort of come together given what you
know we currently know about fungi but
of course without being able to actually
have a
a record of what would have happened um
during the time of the dinosaurs
uh well i i mean i i'd like to read
outside my field and i pride myself that
every day i try to read something about
my outside my field and the asteroid
hypothesis came to be
in the early 80s when it was
when an iridium level was found and
that's what gave the clue that it came
from outer space between indicate the
boundary
but and but i always been bothered by
the question why mammals
now people say well you know you had a
calamity
and uh and it created space and the
mammals moved in because the dinosaurs
are not there that doesn't make any
sense to me you know you still have
reptiles
you still have others why do you end up
selecting something that needs so much
food
you needed to have something at the end
of the day that for which this
temperature provided an advantage
otherwise we make no sense and that's
separate that the birds the birds
already had that advantage in the sense
that they need it they may have had it
for flight but but for the terrestrial
one of us the uh creatures uh and so so
that that always bothered me it never
made any sense to me that people say
well a space got created and the mammals
took over now that you need to have
something and then what happened reading
out reading trying to read in other
areas i came to that article
showing in 2003 of a fungal bloom around
the kt boundary that was a published i
believe he was in science
and
the two things began to make began to to
fit in together
fungal bloom
thermal protection
uh mammalian dominance
so it's really a thought it's it's this
idea comes from we're linking in
very different aspects
uh
facts into into new thought
and is there anything that we can then
you know take from this and
um sort of apply you know if we're if
we're thinking about how to protect
either ourselves as humans or other
animals against fungal infections you
know can we exploit this idea of
temperature as as being sort of
protective
or is there is there somewhere we can
sort of take this and learn from this
i think that yes i think that there's a
lot to do here but maybe first we can
visit the bats so it turns out that the
bats in north america were doing pretty
well up to 2006.
in 2006 a fungus was introduced from
europe that is a coal-loving fungus so
it can only grow at cold temperatures
and began to kill the bats it began in
new york and in new york state and it
spread through a whole continent
and the bats are susceptible in the
winter
not in the summer
so the bats the reason is in the
temporary climates there is no food so
the bats hibernate
the fungus grows on them and essentially
wakes them up in the middle of the
winter because they're sick and they
can't feed and they die if you take
those bats
from the cave to the laboratory and feed
them
just giving them food dries up their
metabolic rate and they can clear the
fungal disease
that's giving you a tremendous
uh uh
powerful
anecdote or the power of temperature
another example are the frogs that are
infected with the ketrick fungus if you
bring them into a lab and you put them
at 37 degrees you can cure them of the
kid drink
so
uh so
it is possible so there are a couple of
things you can think of you can think of
that for infectious diseases that are
acquired from the environment
that we may be able to exploit
temperature that perhaps we shouldn't be
giving everybody tylenol
uh when they have a severe fungal
disease that the temperature increasing
the temperature could
make the fungus more susceptible to to
uh
to to the to the internal environment
the other thing to think about is
that temperature pathways may be
targeted in drug development
uh we know very little
about how do you adapt to higher
temperatures
this is an area that you know almost let
me give you a thought example almost
everything we know in immunology is done
at 37 degrees
but immunology in your skin happens at
31 degrees
you would think
that
that that there has to be a lot of more
research
looking at a temperature as a variable
in all aspects of microbial pathogenesis
but yes i think that that it is uh it is
something that we currently don't target
so it is a target to me it's a target
for exploration of possible opportunity
very cool
um
and
you know so
sort of centering this around
um
reptiles and the dinosaurs and and the
sort of um
uh
advantage of mammals but
you know to today we know that
certainly humans and other i think other
mammals
are still to a certain extent
susceptible to fungal disease so is this
is this just sort of the exception to
the rule or where does sort of human
vulnerability to fungal infection than
fit in
so i think that
the fungal diseases emerge in the 20th
century as a major we know tuberculosis
from antiquity we know
a lot of diseases from a long time but
fungal diseases really begin to take
over up to 1950. what happens in 1950
corticosteroids are developed
chemotherapy is developed then in the
1980s you have the hiv epidemic what do
all these things have in common
they
interfere with
our immunity
so there are two pillars
to our uh resistance
one pillar is immunity advanced immunity
having t cells b cells innate immunity
you name it
and the other one is temperature
so what we saw in the 20th century was
that if you mess around with the pillar
of immunity you get more fungal diseases
what we are afraid of to see in the 21st
century is
that the fungi may adapt and then defeat
or mess with our second pillar
but i think
it is a fact that immunologically
competent mammals
are remarkably resistant to fungal
disease they do occur but they are very
rare and what we are learning now with
genomic analysis is that when you when
they occur
they often tend to be some sort of error
for example a mutation in detecting
pathway or signaling or something like
that that said that sets it apart so i
would focus more on the remarkable
resistance and try to understand that
rather than the susceptibility because i
think we the susceptibility that has
many causes and you can certainly
by the way drugs transplants and things
like that to me that's uh a very
interesting scientific question
definitely yeah i think in in our
current
pandemic era i think we're we all you
know i think everyone is very attuned to
thinking about kind of human
vulnerabilities and and immunological
kind of susceptibilities so it's very
interesting
um
you know i mean it's it's certainly kind
of a
an out there theory and and is you know
different i think from you know what we
are used to thinking about and not
necessarily intuitive to kind of center
this important
um
event around uh these kind of fungal
species and the impact that they've had
so has has there been sort of pushback
to this theory are there are there you
know people
think otherwise
it's one possibility that nobody cares
another possibility is that people say
well you know it's it's um
you know it's it may be and and they but
but what i would say to you is that as a
scientist you know there are three big
questions
what how and why i mean i'm on the other
big question societies are pretty good
at
what we describe stuff
now people like to work on mechanism
that's how you do it but we tend to stay
away from the why
the why gets into often gets people very
um
very you know worried uh you get into
metaphysics you get into
into technological reasoning whatever
but i am interested in all three and to
me
the why questions it really often
explain a lot of the world as it is
so uh to me a lot of this came from i'm
trying to understand the why question
why mathematics
it to me that's a really interesting
issue
uh that if that need
needs an explanation and whatever was
out there was certainly
uh not sufficient uh for me
and it's been a lot of fun look this is
something you can you can talk at a
cocktail party you know i mean
i can't talk about my other work at a
cocktail party without having everybody
leave yes
maybe maybe i'll just jump in to remind
any of the audience members that if they
have any questions they should feel free
to drop them into the q a section of the
webinar
um and while i have the microphone i
might uh take the opportunity to circle
back to some of the questions around
temperature and make a connection with
climate change
um
what do we
do we think that climate change may
affect fungi and if so if so how
what about their ability to cause
infection yeah so we have one example
again in this explanation it falls into
a white question i post it to you
candida auris was unknown to medicine
until 2007. you can't find it in any
collection you cannot in 2010 and 2011
it emerges simultaneously in three
continents
and they are genet there and they are
not the clades are different so these
are not that somebody took it and flew
from one country to another three
continents
why would that be
why would you have this thing emerge at
the same time and then you mean you may
begin to look and say what is happening
in common on the three continents and
you know we have proposed that this may
be the first example of an organism
adapting to higher temperature and
breaking through the thermal barrier now
whether it is right or not i don't know
uh it was just recovered in the andaman
islands it turns out that the wild
isolate is or it was less temperature
adapted than the ones that they
recovered from a beach that could have
been put there by humans so what i what
i would argue is that we need to focus
why questions are fun why questions can
drive all kinds of research and they can
also open the areas that we don't know
that could also be
be addressed
good thing we have a program called
fungal kingdom threats and opportunities
well i'm glad you do yeah
so um i'll read another question that's
come in from the audience um and they
they ask if if you have any comments on
how long the dinosaur extinction event
would have taken how abrupt was the
fungal bloom and how long would a fungal
infection take to kill a dinosaur
so i guess i began by saying i don't
know but and then once you say i don't
know i think we can say things like well
there is evidence people have found
evidence that they may some may have
survived
the initial blast uh it's it's really
not clear whether they all died in
around a few weeks of that horrible day
65 million years ago or whether in some
parts of earth some survive to then
subsequent to one extinct
i think the fungal bloom would have
taken
weeks to months to years you need to
have vegetation dye and we know what
happens in the forest it takes a while
for things to begin to decay under but
but it's probably we will be dealing
with decades
if not hundreds of years
of massive uh numbers of fungal spores
and where whatever survived had to deal
with them
well so a related question that has come
in is asking whether
when species became extinct might be
directly linked to the body temperature
um so the question is related to the
seropods that have 37 degrees celsius
body temperature uh which became the
dominant species in the early jurassic
period
yes so so that but people said to the
way to refresh that question is how do
the f there is some evidence there is
actually some evidence dinosaurs were
warm-blooded how does this fit well
remember notice what i'm saying i'm
saying that the the great
killing of this group of organisms was
the calamity
there is even though they you know the
the idea of high temperatures in them
may come from the fact that they are
enormous masses
and there anything and just having all
that cytoplasm metabolically will drive
up the temperature but i don't think we
have any evidence that they regulated
the temperature like we do
or that they would have been able to
maintain those temperatures when when in
in a situation
of dropping global temperatures
a lack of food
so i think that that it's not a problem
for this hypothesis because
the the postulation is those large ones
probably were the top of the food chain
and that would have been in deep trouble
in the calamity whether they were right
near it or on the other side of the
earth
we're almost out of time so maybe i'll
close with um with one last question but
the question is if fungi have haven't
traditionally co-evolved to be human
pathogens will increased tolerance to
higher temperatures by climate change be
enough to make them
serious
human pathogens
so what
people try people often say you know or
you know becoming a pathogen is a good
thing what is the data for that
in fact i would argue that most microbes
pay a price in getting the capacity for
virulence what does it give you well it
gives you a new place to grow and it may
give you transportation if you get into
an animal they can be moved around but
when we actually wrote an article about
the cost of virulence
so when people say well why haven't the
fungi adapted well you know what this
may not necessarily be in their best
interest or there may have been no
selection pressure for it but but i
think that that if we get more it will
be
by accident you will basically end up
raising the temperature the the thermal
temperature of which they can grow
because they have to live in a warmer
world and some of them will be loaded
with the characteristics that will allow
it to cause disease there is no
intelligence behind this
there is just
evolution and selection
well thank you both so much for sort of
a whirlwind tour and a fascinating talk
on what is a fascinating hypothesis so
thank you so much to arturo casa duvall
and to rebecca shapiro for sharing your
your insights with us today um and thank
you to all the audience members for
joining in
um we'll have a recording of this talk
available on our website cfr.ca um
likely sometime early next week so thank
you all for having me it's been a lot of
fun science is a lot of fun
that's right
thanks wonderful thank you
thank you
[Music]
you